[Music]
the teaser for Mary Poppins returns yeah
we released and what a tease it was so
we did get to see a glimpse of you doing
the iconic yeah Briella flight yeah that
is so iconic and cool what was going
through your mind the first time you got
to do that whether I thought I was going
to die 50 feet in the air yeah it's yeah
I'm not amazing with Heights and it was
one of those things where they kind of
winch you up there and then there's the
moment before they bring you down for
the shot and there just seems like that
moment extends to sort of forever
timeframe and and it's so you're so high
that if you look out you're higher than
the trees if you look down
lin-manuel Miranda was like that and so
I just ended up being like that just
like waiting for Rob to call action and
and then you play fabulous yes we always
do before sin because actually no set
turn over and you go actually what you
do that's none of my crap but it was an
incredible moment you know hey it's very
very disarming what was it like working
with lin-manuel awesome so talented so
cool it is wonderful to see you
yesterday isn't it
[Music]
[Applause]
you